et jean du monde des affaires à paris 6
pierre fils kevin sont contents de
savoir que quelqu'un de cette envergure
look accepte de l'an politique pierre
fitzgibbon re devient ministre de
l'économie de l'innovation du québec
qu'il avait été forcé de quitter son
poste début juin après avoir reçu un
nouveau blâme de la commissaire à
l'éthique parce qu'il détenait des parts
dans deux entreprises faisant affaire
avec le gouvernement
pierre fitzgibbon a vendu au cours des
dernières semaines ses parts dans ces
entreprises non cotées en bourse pierre
fait qu'il donne est avec nous ce soir
plaisir de vous recevoir bonsoir bonsoir
monsieur fillion alors monsieur fait des
bonnes vous avez pu si j'ai bien compris
finalement vendre vos actions pour vous
soumettre au code d'éthique vous avez
dit ce matin c'est pas une très bonne
transaction financière qu'est ce que ça
veut dire
octet comme vous savez probablement une
société privée y ait pas de valeur
marchande donc soudain une dévaluation
qui va partir une personne donc je vais
peut-être pu avoir une mère transaction
mais c'est pas grave c'est derrière moi
donc j'ai j'ai accepté de confirmer au
code de déontologie dont il dispose et
les actions est ce que vous dites c'est
pas grave aujourd'hui finalement vous
avez sans doute peut-être un peu perdu
d'argent dans tout ça vous n'avez pas eu
le prix que vous auriez vous dit est ce
que vous auriez pas dû après coup agir
bien avant avant d'avoir les trois black
kids est obligé de démissionner octet
s'il y avait eu des actes que j'avais
posé qui aiment et amis en conflit
d'intérêts se pose ce soit avec vous
donc mon dossier n'est pas tâche et j'ai
jamais commis d'acte dans ma carrière
professionnelle qui a fait un stage est
en conflit ici on parle d'interprétation
et j'avais mis en place des procédures
des mesures pour ma péché pas profiter
maintenant le code éthique son
interprétation au jus différemment donc
la question durant l'été pour moi était
est ce que je veux revenir ou non à mon
poste de ministre et j'ai répondu oui
parce que j'aime juste hull et
conséquemment j'ai accepté de me
soustraire ou de conformité au code de
la place mais est ce que vous regrettez
pas un peu je vous pose la question
parce que ça a quand même été long les
blancs d'oeufs supplémentaires vous
dites que votre dossier n'est pas
entachée mais il ya des gens qui ont
l'impression que vous étiez un conflit
d'intérêt ou que vous dit y avait
apparence de conflit d'intérêts puisque
vous arriver à cette décision
aujourd'hui
après coup est ce que vous vous dites
peut-être que j'aurais dû le faire dès 9
heures
non une réponse ne regarde jamais en
arrière et comme j'ai dit j'ai eu dans
ma tête j'ai pas eu d'acte le fautif
maintenant je voulais redonner et je me
conforme aux règles d'une telle
qu'établie
considérez vous que vous avez fait le
choix maintenant entre votre poste de
ministre et vos intérêts financiers
personnels
acté définitivement nous aurait été la
production me su poser c'est est-ce que
je veux revenir à mon poste de ministre
on s'était oui parce que d'une part
j'aime ce une fierté travaillé pour le
gouvernement j'ai une fierté d'être avec
mes collègues et c'est un poste qui me
stimule beaucoup donc je disais je
reviens dans mon post de conseils de dvd
savoir conséquemment j'ai disposé des
actions vous avez dit ce matin que vous
revenez pour finir votre travail est ce
qu'on doit comprendre que vous ne vous
présentez pas nécessairement aux
prochaines élections que vous êtes là
pour la prochaine année du mandat non
j'ai confié à monsieur legault que je me
présentais je veux solliciter un autre
mandat en 2002 parce que ce travail qui
de longue haleine je pense qu'on a fait
de bonnes choses depuis trois ans il
reste beaucoup il les pandémies je suis
très très satisfait de nos divisions de
notre note fondation alors je vais
exécuter leurs joueurs par manix enviée
pour continuer à exécuter et on va voir
pour un 2e mandat peut commencer en 2022
maintenant que vous vous pliez au code
d'éthique parce que c'est ça finalement
au bout du camp est ce que vous
considérez encore qu'il faut les légers
le moderniser le code d'éthique
actis je suis biaisé en répondant mais
des victimes est inconnu c'est que je
pense qu'ils datent d'une autre époque
je pense que des moynier alternative de
protéger les gens parce qu'effectivement
commettre des fautes de confier ts n'est
pas acceptable pour un politicien ceci
je suis totalement d'accord avec ça
maintenant comment on met en place les
balises pour empêcher surveiller
différents moyens contemporains
d'ailleurs la commissaire à l'éthique
elle même dans son rapport qui a été mis
en 2019 hydro québec
des amendes c'est pas moi qui l'inventé
je pense que ça va devoir être fait en
temps et lieu c'est pas une priorité
honnêtement pour le gouvernement
aujourd'hui mais il est possible dans
votre esprit qu'un ministre de
l'économie ait des intérêts financiers
dans une entreprise non cotée en bourse
avec laquelle le gouvernement fait des
affaires comme celle de bord mis les
mesures en place la compagnie que vous
qu'elle vous référer le jour je suis du
ministre l'économie j'aime assez la
société touch actionnaires elle n'aurait
aucune transaction avec le gouvernement
ce qui était le corps certes le pays de
condé doux et les vidéos d'exister
certes le pays des peyrères derrière il
ya jamais eu aucune opération entre le
gouvernement sous ma gouverne et
l'entreprise donc il un moyen âge était
membre du conseil d'administration de la
caisse de dépôt par exemple été exécuté
la banque nationale de toutes sortes de
mesures mettent en place pour permettre
des gens d'avoir des déplacements mais
ça demande
d'être un mot sur le passeport vaccinale
monsieur legault a dit ce matin que les
employeurs ont le droit d'imposer le 26
à leurs employés si les employés veulent
revenir au bureau
est ce que est ce qu'on devrait imposer
le passeport vaccinale de passer de
vaccins dans le fond aux employés aux
travailleurs qui veulent revenir dans
les entreprises dans les bureaux
que je pense que mon collègue christian
dubé a été clair sur ce on doit
commencer par le minimum services de
l'essentiel pour les entreprises je
pense qu'ils étaient importants qu'ils
offrent à leurs employés et à leurs
clients un environnement sain est-ce que
l'emploi devrait l'exigé je pense est
laissé à l'employeur décidé pour le
gouvernement nous je pense que la preuve
qu'on a prise présentement considérant
les certitudes du lot et de dire ballon
avec et ses besoins essentiels et on
verra en temps et lieu parce que vous
vouliez que l'ailé l'école membres sont
importantes en même temps pouvoir le
côté des hospitalisations de chances
pour que ce gouvernement imposer à tout
le monde à elle des employeurs une
balance des inconvénients il faut
évaluer ici je pense que
fondamentalement pour protéger les
employés et les clients merci monsieur
fait des bonds au plaisir